wholesale Capital markets our stock
markets you name it we're looking at it
to see how we can ensure that we have
the most competitive and Dynamic
Financial Services industry in the world
because that's how we'll deliver on what
you're asking vencat is how we'll make
sure that the billions if not trillions
of pounds of capital that exist can all
be invested in those companies to make
sure they can deliver growth and jobs
here in the UK it's one of the Fantastic
opportunities of brexit we are seizing
that opportunity and working with you
that's how we're going to fuel the
growth of the future right
well we'll leave that event there for
now if you want to continue to watch the
Prime Minister being questioned by
Business Leaders you can do so by
scanning the qrq code on the screen
right now and that will take you to our
online and digital Platforms in the
meantime we're going to go back to
Morris button the organizer of City week
of course Morris uh very interesting
there the first question was from C.S
bank at the Barclays chief executive all
about financial services did you take
any encouragement from what you heard
there well I think the Prime Minister
generally speaking of us for being very
pro-business and and it's important that
he should be I mean the the roads and
the hospitals and the social services
the country needs come from a successful
economy a growing economy one that's not
too fettered by undue regulation and so
on so I take great great comfort from
that and of course financial
institutions and financial services
drive the economy they finance the real
economy so anything which is
pro-business is pro Financial Services
we welcome that worth pointing out from
services employment is actually up some
000 since before the pandemic so it's a
sector that's thrived pretty well
regardless of the broader backdrop yes
yes it is because it's extremely
International so whilst has a very
strong domestic Financial Services
industry here in the city everybody
Prides themselves on how International
their services are and it's one of the
largest exporters of financial services
in the world
do you think the cup the public the
country's a home and you mentioned that
this event was launched in the aftermath
of the financial crisis when let's face
it the banking sector in particular was
in the doghouse does does the broader
public appreciate the importance and
strength of the financial services
sector do you think I I'm not sure that
they do and that that's really as a
matter of education and communication
and perhaps Financial Services could do
a better job in that regard what about
digitalization in particular we I
mentioned AI machine learning I mean
these are all things that the industry
is having to think about very carefully
where is the UK compared with some of
its Global peers on this I think on
digitization there are two parts to it
if you're talking about digital assets I
think the UK is a leader in digital
assets we have a thriving industry
tomorrow will be devoted to digital
assets and it'll be surprised to see the
level of adoption from conventional if
you like financial institutions we get
tokenization the fractionalization of
ownership of assets then there's a
broader issue of the impact of things
like Ai and in due course Quantum
Computing and later on from that Quantum
powered AI which is I don't think
anybody fully understands the
implications of that yet yeah Before I
Let You Go more it's obviously you've
got hundreds of delegates here today are
you hearing much about the CBI and its
current woes is that something on
people's agenda well it's early days for
discussions about that here and that
we're only a couple of hours into the
event but generally speaking I think
people take a very negative view of
what's happened at the CBI understand a
bit and it's totally shocking do you
think the CBI has a future uh I think
it's very hard to speculate on that I
think if there's a clear out of the top
management and a relaunch of the CBI
then I think it has a future but failing
that people have questions whether there
is a need we have quite a few other
representative bodies who knows not
least the city UK further Financial
Services sector Morris appreciate you
thank you very much
some of today's other business news
stories now and and some of today's
other stories now then I just mentioned
the new director general of the CBI
starts work today it's the organization
seeks to stem the flow of the
organizations leaving it either
canceling their membership or pausing
their involvement with the employer's
organization well Rayne Newton Smith was
the cbi's first Chief Economist but she
left last month to take up a senior role
with Barclays a clutch of companies
including Aviva and NatWest group the
John Lewis partnership and Kingfisher
all cut ties with the CBI on Friday
following a second rape allegation being
leveled at CBI employees so the
organization is expected this week to
respond to a report by Fox Williams a
law firm that was commissioned to carry
out an impended investigation into the
allegations
Swiss suffered out flows of 61 billion
Swiss Francs some 55 billion pounds
worth of withdrawals during the first
three months of the year the money was
pulled by both depositors and clients of
its wealth management on as concerns
over its Financial Health Group
following the collapse of the U.S lender
Silicon Valley Bank or Credit Suisse
which has since been rescued by its
larger rival UBS said that the outflows
had moderate it but have not yet
reversed
the healthcare services provide a
Medical Group which supports Hospital
radiology departments has become the
latest London listed company to agree to
a takeover by private Equity buyer it's
agreed to a takeover by ik Partners the
private Equity firms specializing in
investments in northern Europe in a deal
valuing it at 269 million pounds or
Medicare which was founded in 2004 which
floated on the stock market five years
ago is a specialist in tele Radiology
the transmission and display of
radiological images such as CT scans and
x-rays in a location independent of
where the patient is situated
on the average some being required of a
first-time buyer has risen to a record
963 pounds had emerged this morning that
was up two percent to year on year and
up 0.2 percent on last month well the
Figures were published by the online
property portal right move which
revealed that the asking price for an
average home is now 366
247 pounds
well that was up 1.7 percent on last on
last year add up 0.2 percent on last
month's Rightmove said the increases
were lower than were typically seen at
this time of the year
now one of the key themes at City week
is digital assets and in particular how
the potential of emerging digital asset
ecosystem can be fully realized or
joining me now is Barney Reynolds he is
the global head of the financial
services Industry Group at the law firm
Sherman and Sterling Barney good to see
you this morning all of the media noises
around crypto currencies but digital
assets is actually much bigger and much
deeper than that you're right it's a
vast Arena basically every existing
financial asset can be digitized and
it's being digitized and in fact you can
digitize any legal entitlements at all
and trade them so interesting properties
cars you know rental homes or whatever
so it's a very exciting development now
at the center of this in this country is
the Bank of England looking at a central
bank digital currency sometimes referred
to as britcoin do you think this is
going to happen it might they're looking
at it carefully I mean essentially the
the thing that they're trying to solve
for is the digital world needs an
on-chain digital payment instrument and
it might be that the Central Bank needs
to step in and offer its own in order to
continue its control of the currency and
managing the value of sterling
alternatively there are various other
solutions that may private sector
solutions that may prevail do you think
these Central Bank digital currencies
can co-exist with crypto
I do
um I don't see why not I mean I think I
think if it's properly managed a central
bank digital currency uh will provide a
stable payment instrument for the market
uh and be quite attractive now obviously
there are issues that come with that
privacy being a well-known one
um and also you know it effectively
potentially puts the center the
Commercial Banking sector at risk of a
flight uh by depositors to the central
bank digital currency because obviously
that's safer issued by the Central Bank
rather than by a commercial bank so
there are some big issues to be
navigated around that well quite so I
mean you don't really think that this
poses a threat to financial stability
though if it's handled in the right way
not if it's done in the right way and
that's what the thinking uh that's going
on is is all about has the UK lost any
ground term I mean for example The
People's Bank of China already has their
cbdc up and running right in trial I
mean to some degree I mean uh I don't
think that's Grand lost no I mean the US
hasn't uh introduced one yet ECB is is
proposing to but we're not I don't think
meaningfully behind it I think it
matters I think the main thing is if we
do it to do it right and what about the
regulatory environment where would you
put the UK in that regard well there we
have a fantastic opportunity because a
lot of the world's mucked up on digital
assets
um I think the offshore the first Mark
the sort of first phase of digitization
has been marked by businesses using
offshore centers offshore Financial
Centers in the Caribbean and around the
world and in the case of FTX the blow up
of FTX the sort of credibility of those
zones is somewhat
um in question
and in the FTX the US had sort of
essentially allowed its legal system to
manage FTX and there was an onshore FTX
business in the US we hadn't allowed
them into here so they're sort of
bruised by that and The credibility of
the US system is somewhat in question so
the opportunity for us now is to come up
with something that is um like a magnet
which plays on the fact that we have the
most trusted legal environment and
Regulatory system globally so everyone
everyone will wish to come here and set
up here and I'm hearing that from the
market I'm hearing that from clients
that's good to hear what are going to be
the challenges though in getting there
so it's a difficult thing to do it's
deceptively I mean our system is
deceptively simple and that's you know
in a way it's genius but it's very hard
work to make it work well the
governments are already Consulting
sensibly on in the treasury we've got a
very thoughtful paper out there's a lot
of work to be done which is mapping the
digital assets out there in the world in
in sort of real terms onto our concepts
of Regulation and then adjusting our
Concepts to to fit properly which will
mean stripping away some rules where
digital assets get rid of risks that
exists in traditional form and also
adding some rules where digital assets
create new risk and that tailored
approach really is is is something that
the UK is going to excel at and it's
already starting to happen the good
thing thing is others who've been trying
to do it haven't done it in a very
sophisticated way so the EU for instance
has got something where they've
introduced sort of Concepts from a
library e-money tokens and asset
reference tokens which you know bring
into play all sorts of debates about
what's in them and what isn't the genius
of our system is to take simple Concepts
and map them in a much more intuitive
way if we do it right it'll be fantastic
and I think we can ah good news on which
to end Barney great to see you this
morning enjoy the rest of the city right
thank you
live we're gonna have a look at how
Global markets are doing this Monday
morning don't go away
[Music]
foreign
might be to themselves
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Sky's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
[Music]
okay it's okay don't worry it's okay
they're becoming very sensitive
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
every time they touch them they spray
spray
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain
worlds I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake
[Music]
well Equity markets in the Asia Pacific
region had a mixed session overnight
ahead of what is going to be a big week
for corporate earnings only Mumbai and
Tokyo posted gains across the region
overnight well in Europe stocks have
similarly had a fairly muted session so
far this morning and remain largely in
negative territory here's the current
picture talking points in Europe this
morning include Phillips the Dutch
Healthcare technology specialist is
there by some 10 percent after its first
quarter earnings came in ahead of
expectations well here in London the
ftse 100 is also in negative territory
right now not great deal going on really
to be honest with you some of the mining
heavyweights dragging on the index in
fact following a decline in metals
prices leading Blue Chip gainers this
morning though again for is a dalis
group the car parts maker is a heads on
one and three quarter percent that's
that's it shareholder register continues
to evolve following its spin-off last
week for a Melrose group other leaders
in the ftse this morning include the
medical equipment supply convertek
that's following newsletter last week of
an acquisition in the technology space
that seems to have gone down quite well
outside the ftse 100 well again there
are not that many stories for Traders to
get their teeth into right now but Asos
the online fashion retailer it Shares
are off by some two percent right now
that's following press reports that it's
being targeted by a well-known short
seller foreign exchange markets well
again it's actually quite quiet not an
awful lot of volatility uh right now and
certainly not much movement among the
main currency pairs Sterling uh up a
fifth of one percent against the US
dollar more or less unchanged right now
against the Euro The single currency
mean mile is ahead by quarter of one
percent against the Greenback as for the
oil price well that's been drifting this
morning on the continued speculation
about what Rising interest rates are
going to do for Global growth Brent
crude has been trading this morning at
its lowest level since the 31st of March
currently a barrel of Brent crude will
set you back 81.38 cents a barrel that's
off a third of one percent well with me
this morning is Janet Murray she's head
of market analysis at Brewing dolphin
Janet great to see you
um a lot of profit warnings out lately
many of them from the tech sector yeah
hi good morning Ian thanks for having me
here yeah indeed um there has been a
number of profit warning from companies
especially for the tax sector and
primarily the reason is because of
economic uncertainty so there was a
survey out today by ey and the companies
were citing that there is so much
economic uncertainty and that's why a
lot of businesses are pulling out that
contract putting it under review or
canceling all together and that of
course will have an impact on the
businesses of these companies especially
the tech you know software companies
because these businesses are quite
cyclical so when there's economic
downturn the first thing that company
usually cut is advertising or spending
on Tech investment Etc so that's why
we're getting more and more of that
profit warning now it's quite
interesting that you're talking there
about the fundamentals of the businesses
because obviously there was a big
sell-off in Tech last year that was
largely driven by higher interest rates
and that obviously changes the way that
investors look at Future cash flows
absolutely I mean what I mentioned was
the economic uncertainty of course High
interest rate has a role to play in that
because ultimately High interest rates
would make economic slowdown more likely
and of course it really puts funding
pressure on the company so the companies
outside in this survey also said it is
getting hotter and harder to get access
to funding especially for smaller tech
companies so that's why I think it will
be quite a difficult challenging
environment for these small and
mid-sized companies trading in the UK
that's a huge week this week for
corporate earnings I mean we're we got
off to a reasonably Good Start q1
earnings season what are you going to be
looking at for this week well this way
is a huge earnings week for the UK for
banks basically we have most of the
large banks in the UK reporting and of
course I think most people will be
watching for the net interest rate
margins
um how sustainable that is going to be
of course the guidance on that going
forward because we we had a pretty good
run in terms for banks in terms of their
profit profitability but that is likely
to be challenged given that we are
having the squeeze in the margin going
forward because the bond deals have gone
lower and of course the assets as I
mentioned the access to credit is
getting more and more difficult so I
think that would be a key thing to watch
and whether these banks will be
tightening their lending standards to
the businesses what's really struck me
though thus far earnings have actually
been pretty good and particularly uh you
know you look at something like Philips
today the share price up 10 so investors
have been a little bit pessimistic in
terms of the Outlook at times it seems
yeah I think that the the fact is a lot
of people are worried about the economic
uncertainty and certainly the earnings
growth expectation have been dealt by
back you know consistently so I think
the expectation has been lower so it is
relatively you know easier to beat the
focus of course it is still difficult
but I think because people have already
lowered the expectation But ultimately I
think the sentiment out there is still
pretty doubtful there is a rally year to
date but I think a lot of analysts out
there are saying that this is not
sustainable because we are likely to see
more economic slowdown economic data has
been resilient and better than expected
but who knows because we have still to
observe the lacked impact of interest
rate Rises and of course the impacts
from all these banking stress that we've
experienced which is may not be visible
yet yeah none energy is obviously uh
always close to people's thoughts right
now the story caught your eye this
morning about a big anglo-dutch
initiative yeah so the government has
announced that they will have a cable
underneath the North Sea connecting the
UK and the Netherlands called the line
ink so that would uh basically link the
offshore wind farms in the North Sea and
connecting the electricity generated
between UK and the Netherlands so it
will increase the current UK gen
electricity generation capacity by 20
but that is likely to start I mean the
project is only going to be completed
maybe in 2030 so there's still some way
to go but it's a great step in the
direction in terms of our longer term
energy security and of course the
transition to Net Zero and while I've
got you Janet obviously we had quite a
lot of economic data around last week in
particular inflation and earnings data
do you think an interest rate rise is
nailed on next month from the bank of
England I think so I think well first of
all the UK inflation is proved to be
still very sticky we're still over 10
and particularly High relative to the US
and the Eurozone which has said
inflation come down already and also
wage growth is still elevated as well so
I think these factors suggest to us that
the bank of England will be pressured to
deliver another rate hike in May all
right Johnny got to leave it there good
to see you this morning thank you thank
you still to come from the Guild Hall on
in King live the future of sustainable
Finance I'll be joined by the former
chief executive of BP law brand stay
tuned
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Hall at the heart of the city of London
where of course City week is being
staged a gathering of the great and good
here in the financial services sector
just a reminder that the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak is holding a business
connect event as he begins a charm
offensive with corporate leaders if you
want to hear what the prime minister is
saying and watch him being questioned by
Business Leaders you can scan the QR
code on the screen right now and that
will take you over to Sky News online
as we mentioned earlier in the program
the theme for day one of City week is
climate change and in particular how the
UK's Financial Services industry is
supporting the transition to Net Zero
what joining me now is Julia Carboni she
is director of the natural climate
Solutions Alliance at the world Business
Council for sustainable development
Julia welcome to you you better explain
what uh the natural climate Solutions
Alliance is yes well
there but first of all it's on
a lot like a coalition of different
stakeholders we have around 60
organizations at the moment and we have
three groups we have businesses we have
ngos and solution providers in the space
of climate change
the main focus of the NCS Alliance is to
catalyze demand for high quality natural
climate Solutions purchased on the
voluntary carbon Market yeah so for the
uninitiated what is it a voluntary
carbon market so the voluntary carbon
Market is the place where buyers and
sellers Exchange Credit like a
certificate that represents one ton of
carbon equivalent that is being either
reduced or removed and they oh and they
basically purchased that uh certificate
and they own it so there are a lot of
discussions about how to report on it
how to put it in their inventory but
this is to say that the voluntary carbon
Market is not a replacement to what
companies need to do within their own
value chain in terms of decarbonization
is considered a complement an addition
to and it's a really good opportunity
for companies to go beyond what they
have already committed in terms of Net
Zero and who do they buy these credits
from that's a good question there are a
lot of players out there so that's also
creates a little bit sometimes uh I
think ahead especially for companies
that are starting in this business
trying to figure out how to invest right
but there are some sometimes credits can
be purchased directly from what we call
Project developers and other times there
are intermediaries just like in every
market right so their intermediaries
that go out take the credits from the
the project Developers and make them
available sometimes with additional
let's say uh
additional you know packaging around
because they do some kind of reporting
or they do some verification on top but
what we say is that um not all carbon
credits are the same well I mean if I'm
a big corporate how do I know that the
carbon credits I'm buying are genuinely
going to be reducing carbon emissions
that's the key question today so what is
important is that these credits have
been issued by carbon crediting programs
that are credible and The credibility of
this carbon credit comes from kind of
some kind of accreditation so right now
we have a platform which is corsia that
accredits the carbon crediting program
that can offer credits to The Airlines
and many organizations even if they're
not Airlines use this accreditation as a
kind of like a quasiak you know Global
accreditation but uh
few weeks ago icbcm so the Integrity
Council for the voluntary carbon Market
has issued the carbon the core carbon
principles and the assessment framework
which in the next few months will help
identify which carbon crediting programs
and methodologies are of high integrity
and therefore credible so the people who
are selling these credits their work is
being properly audited yes exactly and
do you eventually see there being a sort
of global standard for this rather than
the way that we have in the accounting
sector you know you have IFRS and GAP
rules for example yes so that's exactly
the the purpose of the icbcm I have to
say I'm a board member so of course I'm
I have a stake in it I really believe in
it the the idea is that this is a
voluntary carbon market and we want the
voluntary is a really important point
because it enables also Innovation new
ideas new experimentations and so on but
still even if it's voluntary you need
some kind of you know regulations and
this is what I see young will come with
at Wester take up most strong right now
so the let's say the the main type of
credits right now are renewable energy
and red which is the reduced emissions
from
deforestation and Forest degradation
actually I would say it's red plus
because they should also contribute to
you know livelihoods and people this is
really important and this is actually
the the main core of the NCS Alliance
which is to promote the voluntary Karma
Market of natural climate Solutions this
is because we feel you know it's it's
known now and ipcc the in the panel for
climate change has also recognized the
role fundamental role that nature has to
mitigate and adapt to climate change so
how do we finance that right it's we we
have a whole list of things we would
like to do but financing nature to that
level is you know at least for the for
uh mitigation is around 400 billion a
year voluntary carbon Market can play a
really important role very good Julia
good to see you this morning thank you
very much
well don't forget to check out the Ian
King live podcast which you can find by
skewing gunning the QR code on your
screen right now it's available where
you get your podcasts including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcast and of
course Spotify and don't forget to keep
looking at our digital platforms
throughout the day here on Sky News
there's a lot of live and breaking news
there my colleague Mark kleiman has been
busy over the weekend breaking a number
of exclusive stories
now staying with the theme of
sustainable Finance following cop 27
joining me now is Lord Brown and Maiden
Lee former chief executive of BP now the
chairman of Beyond Net Zero John good to
see you this morning you've come hot
foot from a panel discussion what have
you been talking about we've been
talking about how to get enough money
into the system uh to keep temperatures
rise down to a safe level we've got to
go from a trillion dollars today to four
trillion dollars almost immediately
that's an enormous amount of money it
needs the right incentives the
measurements and it needs a great blend
of public and private finance and I made
the point the thing about private
finances it comes with companies and
companies of the best vehicle in the
world to deliver and they've got to
deliver against measurable outcomes and
so we've got plenty more to do I've
noticed in in our own work we've been at
this now you know we're investing three
and a half billion dollars and we we do
it against specific measurements and
that works like a wonder and so much
more of that has to happen much more
incentive is needed as well much more is
the capital out there four trillion
dollars Laura money capital is clearly
out there I mean Capital flows to the
returns you know and capital does not
flow when there are no returns uh
obviously different returns for Public
Finance different returns for private
finance and you know a small Gap makes a
big difference so it's all very well
saying you know we've got 20 billion for
this at 100 billion for that we need to
make sure it's the right amount for the
returns needed and and usually there's a
bit of a gap and it's a gap because
sometimes
non-financial things get in the way all
very well financing a wind farm but if
you can't connect it to the grid for six
or twelve years
the finance is very very expensive well
quite I mean the other Big Challenge I
guess is that we are in a rising
interest rate environment right now that
affects the way that investors look at
their returns over the medium to longer
term is it more of a challenge right now
to attract Capital into this into this
field it just requires the right returns
I mean obviously you know if you're
going to make money in a money market
fund you've got to make a premium for
that if you're going to take a risk on
something which is to do with change
energy transition or capturing carbon
and storing it forever so you need the
right returns and they are flexible
against the the cost of capital yeah
exactly I mean that's that's a key point
so has the risk reward ratio changed
particularly leaving aside what's going
on with interest rates well I think good
news is that uh technology improves
every day
bear in mind we have to do we have to
apply it the whole time and it gets
better over time so clearly you can see
that in wind farms and solar farms and
when compared with the way it was even
10 years ago risks are down heavily
risks are very high in areas of carbon
management which is the big thing we
have to do we have to get carbon out of
the system especially as we're burning
oil and gas and we will do so for quite
a long time
because there is no choice you know
there's no choice because we spent so
much time talking and not enough time
doing well one well I mean it's
interesting you mentioned that because
I'm in one particular field of
technology is carbon capture and storage
which a lot of people looked at over the
years decided it was on economic the
technology it feels as though we're
getting closer to it actually being
financially sustainable now and the
technology has been around a long time
now I remember when I was ahead of BP I
mean we used to circulate a lot of
carbon dioxide and natural gas in Pluto
Bay in fact are one of the largest
things and that started in the 80s so
Technologies there cost is high cost is
high cost will come down the more it is
deployed but it needs help again in BP
we try to do this in 2006 there was a
gap which the government was not
prepared to fill
nowadays that Gap is probably smaller it
must be filled by incentives yes just
now you mentioned incentives the right
regulatory backdrop what do you need for
to hear I mean it's not just a question
of what you need to hear from the UK
government this is a global issue so I
think we heard quite a lot from the
United States government with the
inflation reduction act they
unfortunately called our Ira
but that's a whole set of incentives I
mean incentives are very good things
taxes are also good but in the U.S
incentives work better to achieve push
investment into things like carbon
capture and storage energy storage
these sorts of things very important
indeed so we need to emulate that around
the world we shouldn't step back and
ring our hands and say gosh that's bad
we need to do more of it around the
world is Ira going to distort the way
that business decisions are made I mean
someone said to me this is effectively
turning what looked like a marginal
investment decision into a no-brainer
presumably that you must be hearing an
awful lot of that that's correct and I
can see that day to day and the
activities that we do it beyond that
zero so uh yes there's there is
investment competition uh but that
competition can be leveled obviously if
you do the right thing around the world
there's one thing which does get in the
way and that is what happens in the
global South I'd say that the lack of
trust between the global South and the
developed world is getting bigger and
bigger because there is no delivery to
help them adapt to climate change and we
need to fix that otherwise the level of
cooperation will get worse and worse and
people will put their money not
necessarily where it has the most effect
but where politically they get the most
points John before I let you go uh
Central London there are demonstrations
today being staged by a group called
just stop oil what would you say to them
in terms of how the business Community
is trying to lead the transition well
look I deeply appreciate the fact that
people like to fix the problem by direct
action getting rid of carbon I think we
all would but we we can't I mean simply
there's an awful lot of oil and gas
being consumed in the world and it's not
just the UK it's all over the world and
you know the amount is actually Rising a
bit at the moment which is surprising
but it is so my view is focus on how we
can manage the carbon coming out of
Bernie oil and gas focus on that get the
incentives right and then over time the
amount of oil and gas consumed will go
down but right now it won't
your brand John Brown always good to see
you thanks for joining very much
well a reminder that we're here in the
Guild Hall in the heart of the city of
London for City week now it seems to be
said that the three pillars of the city
of London were the bank of England the
London Stock Exchange and the Lloyds of
London Insurance markets well the latter
has been grappling in recent years with
a number of challenges reflecting the
changing nature of risk whether that is
climate change the pandemic the war in
Ukraine and cyber security lots for the
Lloyds of London Market to Grapple with
right now well I'm very pleased to say
that joining me is Bruce Carnegie Brown
he's the chairman of Lloyds of London
Bruce okay good to see you this morning
um clearly a lot of challenges for the
industry right now but what's really
struck me is that demand for insurance
and reinsurance is actually really
buoyant just now yes it certainly is I
think we're getting pricing to a
sensible place which of course is then
bringing more Capital into the
marketplace but to the point you're
addressing I think there are the the
complexity of the problems we're being
asked to ensure is also causing us to
spend lots of time and investment on
developing new products as the risks of
our customers change what about cyber
security in particular that there seems
to be a bit of grumbling from some of
your customers that uh it's being
excluded from some policies and what
we're trying to do is get our arms
around cyber risk one of the Brave
things the insurance industry does is
put a price on a risk it doesn't yet
fully understand and this is of course
an emerging and developing risk for our
customers and for us and so over time as
we understand things better we're trying
to compartmentalize the risk and make
sure of course we are we put enough
Capital behind those risks so that we
can pay our claims and so the thing
that's slightly unnerving our customers
is we're asking our customers to
separate
state-sponsored cyber risk activity from
what we'd call business as usual uh
cyber risk and what we don't want to
have is for instance domestic companies
that are not at risk from
state-sponsored Cyber attack paying for
that cover if they don't need it and so
we're asking people to separate those
things into two policies a bit like in
aviation we separate all risk policies
from war risk policies in aviation so
customers can buy the covers but they
just need to be specific about the
covers they're buying and we think that
creates a better product it's less
efficient capacity in the Lloyd's market
now covering cyber risk well it's an
issue that uh preoccupies me we
underwrite 20 of all cyber Risk
insurance that's done globally in truth
not enough people buy it yet it's an
underinsured risk but we have to think
about our own risk appetites in in
context of our Capital so it's our
fastest growing line of business at
Lloyd's I think that will continue for
some time to come and we want to put
ourselves in a place where we can
continue to support the growth in that
market and demand from our customers but
it does mean being smarter about the way
we evaluate these risks and the capital
we allocate to them now the first big
theme today day one of City week is
climate change I mean fair to say I
think the Lloyds of London Market was
pretty quick onto climate change as
potentially risking the financial system
and the stability of it
well I think that's right so I think our
position is we're already underwriting
the impacts of climate change uh the
biggest part of our capital is allocated
to Natural catastrophe risks around the
world and we see the increase in the
severity and frequency of those risks so
we're already invested in this and again
back to the earlier comment we need to
manage these risks as they develop and
evolve so we needed to get onto it
quickly is there much capacity for
innovation in terms of how you help
customers mitigate the risk of climate
change so we're doing a lot of
investment in that particularly new
technologies that should potentially
deliver sustainable energy Alternatives
a good example would be hydrogen I mean
arguably one of the most sustainable
energy sources but what we also know
about hydrogen is that it's enormously
combustible so we've got Pilots running
in the Lloyd's Innovation Lab at the
moment to try to understand the risks of
hydrogen to see whether we can put
product Insurance products behind that
another good example would be carbon
credits people increasingly interested
in carbon credits now can we ensure the
performance of those credits to give
more confidence to our customers in
using carbon credits to offset their
risks yes you mentioned the Lloyd's
Innovation lab a lot of people may not
necessarily know about this how long has
it been running and what sort of numbers
do you have working in it so we've uh
about about four years into it now we
typically have a cohort of some 10
Innovation uh businesses typically small
businesses either selling an idea or a
service or looking for insurance
capacity behind a product we're now in
our ninth cohort so nine multiplied by
ten we've had 90 businesses come through
and a number of them have moved into
scale-ups and attractive Capital to
support them parametric insurance has
been a product that's been quite heavily
developed in the marketplace we have a
business called parcel that started
actually as a sensor business going into
shipping containers became quite
important in the vaccine program around
the pandemic for keeping vaccines at a
stable temperature when they were being
exported to particularly tropical
environments and that business is now a
Syndicate at Lloyd's with insurance
Capital to support ensuring those risks
for instance and how are you
incorporating things like AI into what
you do
well we have a number of syndicates now
at Lloyd's they're typically still
follower syndicates that are using
algorithms to price risks and we've seen
quite a lot of that in the broader
retail markets we think of price
insurance now being done through price
comparison websites and going into
algorithms to price your Motorcar the
challenge is that even though we've been
underwriting earthquakes for 200 years
putting algorithms around them is quite
hard but we are seeing more algorithmic
Capital uh being applied in the
marketplace and of course we're quite
interested in exploring the risks
presented by AI as well so you know the
most obvious example being motor cars
the the risks move from the individual
to the manufacturer once we start doing
self-drive vehicles for instance and so
understanding how those risks change and
providing product to support those risks
is really important to us now away from
the excitement of City week the cbis
engulfed in Scandal right now Lloyds of
London on Friday I think you announced
that you were pausing your involvement
with the CBI what needs to happen there
realistically well I think they're doing
the right thing they have to pause
re-examine the issues re-examine their
purpose and re-examine the resources
that they have including the people they
have and and rebuild from scratch and as
you know reputation is very easily lost
uh very hard to regain so I'm afraid
it's going to be hard yards for them and
we should all want to be supportive of a
of a strong lobbying group for the
private sector in this country but it
has to have firm foundations and I think
it's starting from scratch again now
I've read okay well before I let you go
you also wear another hat which is
president of the MCC are you confident
for the ashes this summer uh growing in
confidence why wouldn't you start that
way I think it should be a fantastic
summer if we can have good weather I
think it's really set up to be very
exciting England going to win then come
on I'm all there I'm signed up for that
certainly well it was a thriller at
Lords yesterday of course winning their
first championship game yesterday didn't
look likely earlier on in the week so
it's terrific and again at MCC very
supportive of middlesex's success very
good Bruce great to see you this morning
thanks for spread in the tonight thank
you
that's it for me for today from the
Guild Hall City week is going on all
week long there'll be much more coverage
of it here on Ian King live over coming
days and of course there's much more on
the Sky News Mobile app and on the
website with the reporting video content
and Analysis from our business team well
I'm back in the studio tomorrow morning
a bit of a shame match because it's very
exciting here you can feel the uh Buzz
but we'll have lots of guests for you
and again as I say more on City week do
stay tuned after this short break Paul
Kelso will be among the commentators on
the PM speech to business see you
tomorrow cheerio
thank you